alexandria ägypten
vor 2000 jahren ist der hafen der stadt
der größte der welt
berühmt für seinen leuchtturm
und ziel von hunderttausenden seefahrern
händlern und reisenden aus der ganzen
welt
das handelszentrum der antike
doch wie schneidet er in einem vergleich
mit einem der wichtigsten häfen der
neuzeit ab
dem hafen von rotterdam dem größten
europas
[Musik]
150.000 schiffe und 470 millionen tonnen
ladung gehen hier jedes jahr rein und
raus
eine logistische meisterleistung nur
möglich durch hightech und
vollautomatisierung
rotterdam geht als der hafen der zukunft
zwei superlative ihrer zeit im vergleich
kategorie architektur welche hafen hat
den sie handel revolutioniert
kategorie logistik
welcher ermöglicht den größeren
warenumschlag
und kategorie features welche hafen
punktet mit modernster technik
jetzt bei ikonen
[Musik]
wo im heutigen alexandria moderne
containerschiffe und private jachten
anlegen lässt alexander der große über
2000 jahre zuvor den größten handels-
und militär hafen der welt bauen
der riesige seehafen erstreckt sich über
knapp vier kilometer länge und eine
gesamtfläche von elf quadratkilometern
experten schätzen dass damals bis zu 500
schiffe gleichzeitig dort ankern können
ein absoluter rekord
die kapazität und der warnung schlag des
hafens waren weltweit einmalig das
wahrzeichen des hafens und eines der
sieben antiken weltwunder ist der
leuchtturm der berühmte fahrers von
alexandria dank raffinierter technik ist
sein licht noch auf 50 kilometern
entfernung zu sehen weil ich durch den
hafen von alexandria wurde gebührend zu
einer der bedeutendsten handels möchte
und das sollte man schon von weitem
sehen
doch wie sieht der vergleich mit einem
modernen hafen aus
der größte hafen europas ist der hafen
von rotterdam
mehr als 90 terminals
42 kilometer länge und eine gesamtfläche
von
127 quadratkilometer der hafen von
rotterdam ist doppelt so groß wie
manhattan
er ist einzigartig in europa und hat
tiefwasser terminals mit einer
wassertiefe von 24 metern
15 millionen container aus aller welt
werden jährlich in rotterdam
umgeschlagen
der hafen von rotterdam geht als tor
nach europa
der antike hafen von alexandria und der
heutige hafen von rotterdam zwei
superlative ihrer zeit im vergleich
los geht es mit der kategorie
architektur
als erstes welcher hafen ist perfekt für
den schiffsverkehr konzeptioniert
ägypten im jahr 332 vor christus
alexander der große erobert das land und
gründet kurz darauf die stadt alexandria
er hatte sofort erkannt dass die lage
der neuen stadt perfekt ist um einen
großen handels und marina hafen
anzulegen
die große herausforderung für die
architekten die wind- und
strömungsverhältnisse vor der
ägyptischen mittelmeerküste
je nach jahreszeit wie dort ein starker
ost oder west wind
normalerweise kommt der wind muss eine
hauptrichtung und dementsprechend baut
man die hafenmauer und monaco in
alexandria brauchte man quasi einen
rundumschutz
eine mögliche lösung ein komplett von
hafen mauern umgeben das becken wie in
karthago utica oder rhodos der nachteil
die mauern können aufgrund begrenzter
technischer möglichkeiten nur wenige
meter tief ins wasser gesetzt werden
deswegen sind solche häfen meistens
verhältnismäßig klein
für den eroberer alexander kommt das
nicht in frage seine neue prächtige
hauptstadt soll einen der größten häfen
der welt bekommen die architekten
mussten sich also etwas komplett neues
einfallen lassen die lösung sie teilen
die bucht mit einem mächtigen bauwerk in
zwei hälften das sogenannte chapter
stadion ist ein gigantischer damm vom
festland zu der vorgelagerten insel
paros
1200 meter lang und rund 200 meter breit
[Musik]
bis kredite durch entstand ein doppel
hafen mit zwei riesigen praktisch rund
um geschützten hafenbecken
das östliche hafenbecken der portus
magnus hat eine fläche von sechs
quadratkilometern
der westliche hafen genannt portus ist
rund 4 quadratkilometer groß
der clou über kanäle im hefter stadion
können schiffe von einem hafen in den
anderen fahren
ein ausgeklügeltes konzept das den
schiffsverkehr sicher und effizient
macht
während der hafen des antiken alexandria
auf dem reißbrett geplant wurde hat sich
der moderne hafen von rotterdam über
einen zeitraum von 150 jahren entwickelt
heute erstreckt er sich vom stadtzentrum
bis zur nordseeküste
mitte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts liegt
der hafen der handelsmetropole im
zentrum der stadt um ihn an zu laufen
müssen die schiffe von der nordsee rund
40 kilometer über den fluss maß in den
hafen fahren ein riesiger zeitverlust
außerdem ist der fluss ein nadelöhr für
den schnell wachsenden schiffsverkehr
dann drohte damals von der
internationalen schifffahrt
abgeschnitten zu werden das wäre das aus
für die handelsstadt gewesen
deswegen beschließt die stadt einen
neuen zufahrtsweg zu bauen den neue
weiter weg ein 20 kilometer langer kanal
der die in besonders schmalen teil des
flusses ersetzt und selbst die größten
schiffe auf direktem weg in den hafen
bringt
es ist ein mammutprojekt alleine durch
viereinhalb kilometer dünen müssen sich
die arbeiter graben
immer wieder kommt es zu problemen der
frisch ausgehobene kanal läuft mit
schlamm und sand voll die kosten
übersteigen das geplante budget um ein
vielfaches im november 1872 nach neun
jahren bauzeit fährt schließlich das
erste schiff über die neue weiter weg
über den neuen kanal konnten selbst die
großen dampfer rotterdam bequem und
sicher erreichen
das macht rotterdam zu einem gefragten
ziel für schiffe aus aller welt schon
bald ist der alte hafen zu klein man
entscheidet sich ihn zu erweitern und
baut westlich davon den sogenannten wahl
hafen
nach und nach entstehen immer weitere
hafen bereiche entlang des kanals die
die schiffe über abzweigende kleinere
wasserstraßen anfahren können
[Musik]
ein konzept das viele vorteile hat die
festgemachten schiffe liegen geschützt
und auf dem hauptkanal kann der verkehr
ungestört fließen im laufe der zeit wird
der neue vater weg immer wieder vertieft
heute können darauf schiffe mit einem
tiefgang von bis zu 15 metern fahren das
sind 37 cm mehr als im panamakanal
während der antike hafen mit seinem
konzept des doppel hafens überzeugt
punktet der moderne mit der
verkehrsgünstigen verteilung der
terminals entlang des kanals
nächster punkt in der kategorie
architektur welche hafen ist besser für
große schiffe geeignet
[Musik]
in der antike ist es üblich häfen direkt
an flussmündungen zu bauen um eine
verbindung ins landesinnere zu schaffen
der große nachteil starke versandung um
bei ebbe nicht auf grund zu laufen
müssen die großen handelsschiffe weit
draußen ankern
in alexandria konnten dagegen alle
schiffe unabhängig von ebbe und flut im
hafen anlegen
in alexandria entscheiden sich die
architekten gegen den direkten zugang
zum nil und umgehen so das problem mit
der versandung dadurch erreichen sie
eine wassertiefe von bis zu zehn metern
der hafen von alexandria gilt als der
mit abstand tiefste seiner zeit
dank dieser besonderheit ist alexandria
heimathafen des damals größten schiffes
der welt der syrakus
laut überlieferung ist sie um die 100
meter lang und hat genug platz für rund
2000 tonnen ladung 2000 passagiere und
20 pferde
damit ist sie fünfmal so groß wie alle
anderen schiffe der damaligen zeit
diese akkus ja bei eine
ingenieurtechnische meisterleistung
doch durch ihre größe und das hohe
gewicht hat die syrakus ja so viel
tiefgang das alexandria der einzige
harfenistin den sie einlaufen kann so
bleibt sie nach ihrer jungfernfahrt dort
und wird zu einem schwimmenden palast in
sachen wassertiefe setzte legendäre
antike hafen neue maßstäbe
diese akkus bleibt was die länge angeht
für hunderte jahre ungeschlagen
die nächsten 1500 jahren werden schiffe
lediglich breiter und bekommen höhere
aufbauten
[Musik]
als law so lange schiffe aus holz gebaut
wurden waren 100 meter eine magische
grenze
ab mitte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
revolutioniert der stahl den schiffsbau
plötzlich sind schiffe von über 200
metern länge möglich die ingenieure
überbieten sich geradezu mit immer
größeren schiffen
heute messen containerschiffe bis zu 400
meter und haben voll beladen einen
tiefgang von 17 metern
die größten schüttgut frachter für erz
haben sogar einen tiefgang von 23 metern
[Musik]
in meinen vielen helfen ist die größe
der schiffe inzwischen ein problem
hafenbecken können gar nicht schnell
genug vertieft werden
[Musik]
in rotterdam reagiert man schon in den
60er jahren auf die immer größer
werdenden schiffe und baut eines der
größten tiefsee terminals der welt die
maasvlakte wassertiefe stolze 24 meter
dazu wird eine künstliche insel an der
nordseeküste der niederlande angelegt
direkt neben der mars mündung
dafür begann arbeiter 50 millionen
kubikmeter sand aus der nordsee und
schütten ihn aufbauzeit neun jahre
ein gigantischer aufwand der sich lohnt
dank der maasvlakte wird rotterdam für
alle großen reedereien der welt zum
ersten anlaufpunkt in europa
rotterdam ist der einzige hafen europas
in denen jedes schiff der welt voll
beladen einlaufen kann
die nachfrage ist so groß dass die
hafenbehörde die maasvlakte von 2008 bis
2014 um weitere 2.000 hektar erweitert
heute gibt es dort zehn tiefwasser
terminals für die größten
containerschiffe tanker und frachter der
welt
in sachen tiefgang setzen sowohl der
antike hafen als auch sein modernes
gegenstück neue maßstäbe
runde drei in sachen architektur welche
hafen ist effizienter aufgeteilt
[Musik]
die antike hafen von alexandria ist
ähnlich wie heutige moderne häfen in
verschiedene bereiche gegliedert
der östliche hafen der portus magnus
besteht aus vier hafenbecken
entlang der halbinsel loch liegt der
militär hafen bestehend aus zwei
hafenbecken noch auf der halbinsel waren
die königlichen palast anlagen und
gleich daneben die lager für die
soldaten
außerdem bildet der militär hafen eine
barriere er liegt hinter riffen und ist
damit für angreifer nur schwer
anzusteuern
seine eingänge können mit eisenketten
verschlossen werden
neben den beiden becken für
kriegsschiffe gibt es zwei weitere
hafenbecken im portos magnus hier liegen
hauptsächlich die staatlichen
handelsschiffe für den getreideexport
[Musik]
ausländische handelsschiffe haben zum
portos magnus keinen zugang sie laufen
den westlichen hafen an den portfolios
deshalb diese unterteilung hatte mehrere
vorteile die ägypter konnten steuern
einfacher eintreiben außerdem als eine
art schutzmaßnahme man wusste ja nicht
genau wer auf den schiffen war es
konnten verbrecher dabei sein oder leute
mit ansteckenden krankheiten
der porteños ist außerdem über kanäle
mit dem binnenhafen im hinterland
verbunden
waren die für den rest ägyptens bestimmt
sind können so ohne umwege
weitertransportiert werden
der hafen von alexandria war bis ins
kleinste detail durchdacht
in sachen struktur und aufteilung ist
der antike hafen seiner zeit weit voraus
während man früher lediglich zwischen
handels und kriegsschiffen unterschied
ist heute jedes frachtschiff auf ein
spezielles transportgut ausgelegt vom
containerschiff über erz frachter bis
hin zum tankschiff für gas das bestimmt
maßgeblich die aufteilung des hafens von
rotterdam in rotterdam gibt es für jeden
schiffstyp spezielle terminals
so gibt es allein 15 containerterminals
und
26 stück terminals 11 terminals für
rohöl und 16 für andere flüssige güter
wie chemikalien oder für gase dazu
terminals für bienen und
kreuzfahrtschiffe
die terminals für die großen
containerschiffe aus übersee und die
schüttgut frachter sind an der
maasvlakte und dem euro port
nur dort ist genug tiefgang und
ausreichend platz zu manövrieren für die
bis zu 400 meter langen frachter denn
beim an und ablegen müssen die schiffe
drehen
die maasvlakte ist durch ihre
dimensionen einzigartig um die
ozeanriesen zu entladen braucht es
schweres gerät die kräne sind bis zu
125 meter hoch und wiegen bis zu
1.800 tonnen eine enorme belastung für
die ps und kaimauern
[Musik]
beim bau der maasvlakte wenden die
ingenieure deswegen eine neuartige
konstruktions methode an sie verlegen
die fundamentplatte der ps2 meter unter
die oberfläche des aufgeschütteten sand
der sand wird dadurch als eine art
stoßdämpfer und sorgt für eine
gleichmäßige lastenverteilung
sollte sich diese bauart sind einem ps
deutlich höhere last möglich als bei
einem konventionellen bauweise
weiter innen im hafen verteilen sich
dann die terminals für öl und gas an
speziellen kreis pumpen die schiffe ihre
ladung direkt über pipelines in die
großen tanz der terminals
nahe dem stadtzentrum im alten hafen
bereich sind die terminals für schiffe
mit vergleichsweise wenig tiefgang wie
binnenschiffe und auch kreuzfahrtschiffe
diese unterteilung des hafens spart zeit
beim laden und löschen und ermöglicht
einen gigantischen warenumschlag
sowohl der antike hafen als auch sein
modernes gegenstück sind geschickt und
effizient aufgeteilt
[Musik]
zeit für ein fazit in sachen architektur
während der hafen von alexandria durch
seine größe und infrastruktur punkten
liegen die stärken des hafens von
rotterdam in seinem enormen tiefgang und
den hoch spezialisierten terminals
nächste kategorie unseres vergleichs
logistik
als erstes welcher hafen koordiniert den
schiffsverkehr am besten rund 300
handelsschiffe steuern monatlich den
hafen von alexandria an ein gewaltiges
verkehrsaufkommen für die damalige zeit
und die größte herausforderung war den
hafen überhaupt zu finden
denn kompass sie karten und sextant
werden erst rund 1000 jahre später
erfunden
die schiffe siegeln deswegen meist an
den küsten entlang und orientieren sich
an landmarken wie bergen oder hohen
gebäuden
doch die ägyptische mittelmeerküste ist
flach und ohne orientierungspunkte vom
meer aus ist sie erst zusehen wenn das
schiff nur noch wenige seemeilen von ihr
entfernt ist eine große gefahr vor allem
nachts denn in der nähe der küste gibt
es viele risse
diese küste war bei den seeleuten
gefürchtet
um den schiffen den weg in den hafen zu
weisen beschließen die alexandrina am
eingang des hafens einen leuchtturm zu
bauen
und zwar einen wie in die welt noch nie
gesehen hat und der jeden ankömmling in
erstaunen versetzt
[Musik]
den fans von alexandria ein 140 meter
hoher leuchtturm sein lichtsignal reicht
unglaubliche 50 kilometer weit zwanzig
jahre dauert der bau kostet 800 talente
das sind mehr als 20.000 kilo silber
nicht nur für die damalige zeit eine
gigantische summe heute würde das silber
über 14 millionen euro kosten er leitet
die leuchtturm hatte mehrere funktionen
er leitete die schiffe vom offenen meer
zum hafen er markierte die einfahrt zum
portos magnus und der demonstrierte
durch seine größe und die prachtvollen
baumaterialien den reichtum alexandrias
der gigantische turm hat drei abschnitte
der unterste mit 30 auf 30 meter und ist
70 meter hoch der zweite abschnitt ist
ein achteck von 34 metern höhe darauf
steht die eigentliche leucht anlage der
leuchtturm ist komplett mit marmor
verkleidet der anblick ist so
unglaublich dass er bald in der ganzen
westlichen welt bekannt ist
der leuchtturm von alexandria gehört
vollkommen zu recht zu den sieben
weltwundern der antike
bis zu seinem einsturz leitet er 1000
jahre lang schiffe aus aller welt sicher
in den hafen
im hafen von rotterdam setzt man bei der
koordination der schiffe auf hightech
täglich kommen hier allein 70 bis 80
schiffe aus übersee an dazu rund 300
binnenschiffe
damit es nicht zu einem verkehrschaos
kommt muss jede schiffsbewegung minutiös
geplanten von zwei verkehrszentralen aus
leiten und koordinieren deswegen
verkehrslotsen 24 stunden am tag den
schiffsverkehr ähnlich wie an einem
flughafen dafür nutzen sie das so
genannte helmes das hafen management
informationssystem
mit dem system können die verkehrslotsen
die kurse aller schiffe exakt sehen
planen und staugefahr sowie drohende
kollisionen rechtzeitig erkennen und
entsprechend reagieren
parallel zeigt es an welche ladung das
schiff hat und an welchem termin ls wann
anlegen soll
mit diesen informationen leiten die
verkehrslotsen per funk alle schiffe
pünktlich und sicher an ihren
vorgesehenen liegeplatz
das zwischenfazit während der hafen von
alexandria in sachen schiffs navigation
mit seinen spektakulären leuchtturm
punktet leitet der hafen von rotterdam
die schiffe mit modernster technik
nächster punkt in sachen logistik
in welchem hafen ist das beladen und
löschen effizienter
das haupt umschlag gut im antiken hafen
von alexandria ist getreide wegen des
nils ist ägypten schon immer sehr
fruchtbar
die ägypter verbessern bewässerungs und
anbaumethoden schon bald produziert das
land weit mehr getreide als seine
bevölkerung verbraucht
in hochzeiten exportiert ägypten
jährlich
250.000 tonnen getreide zuerst
hauptsächlich nach griechenland später
dann ins römische reich
[Musik]
mit dem ägyptischen getreide control
seine komplette bevölkerung sechs monate
lang versorgen
besondere herausforderung für die
händler und rede wegen der winterstürme
ist die schifffahrt auf dem mittelmeer
in der antike praktisch nur von april
bis oktober möglich
die damaligen schiffe waren nicht für
schlechtes wetter gebaut schon ein
leichter sturm konnte ihnen schwer zu
schaffen machen
das heißt innerhalb von sechs monaten
müssen rund 3500 schiffe mit getreide
beladen werden
dabei setzen die ägypter vor allem auf
muskelkraft
[Musik]
rund eine woche brauchen die arbeiter um
ein schiff mit mehreren tausend säcken
getreide zu beladen
[Applaus]
ein weiteres extrem wichtiges
transportgut in der antike sind amphoren
sie dienen als transport gefäß für alle
möglichen waren wein
oliven früchte milch gewürze oder
fischsauce
römer entwickelten sogar die maßeinheit
am vor das entsprach einem menge von 26
liter
was vor 2000 jahren die amphoren waren
sind heute seefracht container in den
50er jahren von einem amerikanischen
fuhrunternehmer erfunden sind sie
mittlerweile nicht mehr wegzudenken
inzwischen gibt es auf der erde mehr als
eine halbe milliarde dieser stahl boxen
um die containerschiffe so effizient wie
möglich zu löschen und zu laden wird in
rotterdam moderne technologie eingesetzt
in den neuesten containerterminals
funktioniert alles automatisch
doch sie da rotterdam war der erste
hafen mit einem automatisierten termine
inzwischen gibt es in rotterdam 2 der
hochmodernen terminals sie liegen im
tiefseehafen auf der maasvlakte
rund um die uhr kommen hier die größten
containerschiffe der welt an
hat das schiff angelegt beginnen die
automatisierten containerbrücken sofort
mit dem löschen der ladung bis zu 50
container können sie pro stunde vom
schiff heben im schnitt brauchen sie
anderthalb minuten pro container
da pro schiff bis zu sechs
automatisierte containerbrücken
gleichzeitig im einsatz sind spart das
im vergleich zum manuell gesteuerten
containerbrücken mehrere stunden pro
schiff
im kontrollzentrum arbeiten noch
menschen von hier aus steuern sie die
containerbrücken und überwachen die
vorgänge im terminal
an der pier laden die containerbrücken
die container direkt vom schiff auf
sogenannte zivis automatic guided
vehicles
diese führerlosen transportfahrzeuge
bringen die container an ihren
lagerplatz im terminal
vollautomatisch natürlich
eine spezielle software steuert die
kiwis über fast 20.000 in den boden
eingelassene transponder
die kiwis sind batteriebetrieben ist
ihre batterie nahezu leer fahren sie
automatisch zur wechselstation den
wechsel selbst übernimmt ein roboter
nach gerade einmal fünf minuten ist der
mgv wieder einsatzbereit
die menschen müssen eigentlich nur bei
technischen defekten eingreifen
das abladen der container am stellplatz
geschieht ebenfalls vollautomatisch
dank diesem system dauert es gerade
einmal 24 bis 48 stunden bis so ein
container riese gelöscht und wieder
beladen ist
zwischenfazit in alexandria ist das
beladen und löschen dank der muskelkraft
viele ägyptische hafenarbeiter effizient
in rotterdam dank vollautomatisierter
maschinen
dritter punkt in der kategorie logistik
welche hafen hat die bessere anbindung
ans hinterland
[Musik]
der nil ist die hauptverkehrsader für
den inlands transport im alten ägypten
ein großer teil der waren die der hafen
von alexandria umschlägt erreichen oder
verlassen die hauptstadt über den fluss
die ägypter haben auf dem nil einfach
alles transportiert getreide früchte und
sogar die großen steine für die
pyramiden
zwar liegt der hafen von alexandria
nicht direkt am nil trotzdem ist er mit
dem fluss verbunden
dazu bauen die architekten ein geflecht
aus kanälen durch alexandria die drei
wichtigsten sind der kaiserkanal der ii
- tus haffen mündet der nev rotes kanal
wird zum portos magnus führt und der
stier kanal der die beiden anderen mit
dem see mariott verbindet
[Musik]
der see mario liegt südlich der stadt er
dehnt sich in der antike auf über 200
quadratkilometern aus gespeist vom nil
die nil schiffe legen an einem der mario
treffen direkt in stadtnähe an
dort laden die händler die waren
aufbacken um die sie dann über die
kanäle zum hafen bringen
eine einfache effiziente und sichere
methode das spricht sich unter den
händlern schnell herum
wenn ihr schon wenige jahrzehnte nach
dem bau des hafens liefen sämtliche
transporte aus asien über alexandria
elfenbein aus indien öl aus dem himalaya
oder exotische tiere
dank der guten anbindung des seehafens
an den nil wird alexandria zu einer
drehscheibe des handels
[Musik]
während im alten ägypten der transport
fast ausschließlich über den wasserweg
läuft
sitzt man im hafen von rotterdam auf
einen mix aus verschiedenen
transportmitteln
den größten anteil hat dabei mit abstand
die binnenschifffahrt über den rhein ist
der hafen an ein weit verzweigtes
wasserstraßennetz angeschlossen das
praktisch nach ganz west- mittel- und
osteuropa reicht
120.000 binnenschiffe laufen jedes jahr
den hafen von rotterdam an sie
transportieren
153 tonnen waren das macht rund 33
prozent des gesamt umschlages aus ein
binnenschiff kann so viel transportieren
wie 90 lkw
eine weitere wichtige rolle bei der
anlieferung und dem weitertransport der
güter spielt die bahn vor allem güter
deren ziel oder herkunftsort keine
wasserstraße in der nähe hat werden per
zug transportiert
insgesamt elf prozent der güter davon
allein rund eine million container pro
jahr erreichen oder verlassen den ort
hadamar hafen auf schienen
dafür baut man ende der 90er jahre sogar
eine eigene bahn strecke die
betuwe-linie sie ist 160 kilometer lang
und führt von der maasvlakte bis zur
deutsch holländischen grenze
die bahnstrecke ist ausschließlich für
den güterverkehr des hafens dadurch ist
man unabhängig vom normalen zugverkehr
das erhöht die kapazität um ein
vielfaches
für waren mit einem kurzen transportweg
ist der lkw die schnellste und
kostengünstigste variante
[Applaus]
auch hier ist alles auf maximale
effizienz getrimmt bei der einfahrt in
die terminals bekommen die fahrer über
eine chipkarte den platz zugewiesen den
sie anfahren müssen online können sie
sehen ob ihr container schon abholbereit
ist das vermeidet staus an den terminals
die vierte wichtige methode beim
abtransport der güter sind pipelines
rotterdam ist der europäische
umschlagplatz für erdöl und erdgas über
insgesamt
1500 kilometer pipelines werden öl und
gas von den terminals zu raffinerien im
hafen und nach ganz europa gepumpt dank
dieses systems aus verschiedenen
transportwegen schlägt der hafen jedes
jahr 470 millionen tonnen waren um
während im hafen von alexandria der nil
die entscheidende rolle für den an und
abtransport spielt setzt man beim
größten hafen europas auf einen
effizienten mix aus verschiedenen
transportmitteln das fazit in der
kategorie logistik der antike hafen von
alexandria setzt auf die muskelkraft
unzählige hafenarbeiter und auf eine
gute anbindung an den nil der moderne
hafen von rotterdam auf hightech und
automatisierung
weiter geht unsere gegenüberstellung mit
der kategorie features
erster punkt welcher hafen hat die
bahnbrechenden innovationen
alexandria ist das silicon valley der
antike die universität und die
bibliothek der stadt sind auf der ganzen
welt berühmt die bibliothek die heute
nur als neubau existiert gilt als die
größte und umfangreichste der antike um
ihre sammlung anschriften aufzubauen
greifen die alexandrina zu drastischen
mitteln
beamte beschlagnahmen auf den
ausländischen handelsschiffen sämtliche
schriftrollen sie werden kopiert der
besitzer bekommt nur die kopie zurück
das original kommt in die bibliothek
man schätzt dass es in der bibliothek
von alexandria mehr als eine halbe
million papyrusrollen gab
das zieht die größten wissenschaftler
der damaligen zeit an sie erreichen
durchbrüche in der medizin und machen
viele erfindungen
auch die grundlagen der optik sind den
wissenschaftlern in alexandria bekannt
diese nutzen sie auch zum bau des damals
größten leuchtturms der welt sein licht
ist aus 50 kilometern entfernung zu
sehen
wie haben sie das gemacht
erster wichtiger faktor die höhe des
turms die erdkrümmung begrenzt die
sichtweite auf bodenhöhe je höher ein
objekt aus desto größere entfernung kann
man es sehen
zweiter wichtiger faktor das leuchtfeuer
nachts oder bei schlechtem wetter ist es
wichtig ein starkes lichtsignal zu haben
in ägypten war holz mangelware ein
großes feuer kam nicht in frage man
braucht eine andere lichtquellen die
lösung riesige hohlspiegel aus polierter
bronze sie konzentrieren das einfallende
sonnenlicht auf jeweils einen punkt der
extrem hell strahlt nachts dient ein
ölfeuer als lichtquelle dessen
flammenschein ebenfalls von den hohen
spiegeln reflektiert und konzentriert
wird so ist das licht noch in großer
entfernung zu sehen
der leuchtturm von alexandria wird zur
vorlage für andere leuchttürme
seinerzeit
auch im hafen von rotterdam spielen
innovationen eine wesentliche rolle
startups die durch ihre erfindungen die
abläufe im hafen verbessern werden
systematisch gefördert
eines dieser start ups ist rem lab das
unternehmen druckt ersatzteile für
schiffe on demand direkt im hafen mit
einem metall 3d drucker das hat seine
vorteile
normalerweise geht man die teile da sie
oft aus china kommen kann das schon mal
ein halbes jahr dauern
müssen die reedereien das schiff so
lange außer betrieb nehmen bedeutet das
einen verlust in millionenhöhe
metall 3d drucker dagegen stellen die
benötigten ersatzteile innerhalb weniger
tage her
im lichtbogen schweißverfahren schmilzt
der drucker einen metalldraht und trägt
das material schicht für schicht in der
gewünschten form auf ein weiterer
vorteil ist dass die teil aus dem
drucker leichter und oft günstiger sind
als gegossen teile
sogar eine komplette 400 kilogramm
schwere schiffsschraube hat das
unternehmen schon gedruckt
schiffsteile aus dem 3d drucker nur eine
von vielen technologien die rotterdam es
zu einem der modernsten häfen der welt
machen
das zwischenfazit in sachen innovation
und neue techniken setzen beide häfen in
ihrer zeit neue maßstäbe
der zweite punkt in der kategorie
features welche hafen ist der bessere
industriestandort
[Musik]
wo heute im hafen von alexandria
hochhäuser stehen sind vor über 2000
jahren zahlreiche werften angesiedelt
sind die schiffe aus der antike
bestanden ausschließlich aus holz sie
mussten im verhältnis zur heutigen
schiffen oft repariert werden vor allem
in den wintermonaten in denen keine
schifffahrt möglich ist haben die
werften viel zu tun
auch die auftragsbücher der segelmacher
sind immer gut gefüllt denn die großen
handelsschiffe haben aus platzgründen
keine ruderer sie sind auf ihre segel
angewiesen siegel sind daher extrem
wertvoll es kam vor dass ein kapitän
sein ersatz säge verpfändete wenn das
schiff dann in einen sturm kam und das
hauptsegel kaputtging trieben die
schiffe teilweise wochenlang auf dem
meer herum
doch die ägypter sind nicht nur
geschickte segelmacher direkt am hafen
liegt der marktplatz der stadt hier
verarbeiten handwerker die importierten
rohmaterialien und verkaufen die
fertigen produkte wieder an händler
[Musik]
der export schlager schlechthin
räucherwaren die händler kaufen die
rohmaterialien in arabien bringen sie
nach alexandria und verarbeiten sie dort
zu räuchermischungen und seiten
bei rauch war so teuer dass die arbeiter
nur nackt in die fabrik durften damit
sie nichts clown konnten
textilien schmuck und keramik sind
weitere wichtige exportgüter die lage
der werkstätten am hafen spart den
händlern transportkosten und garantiert
viele interessierte kunden
während in alexandria hauptsächlich ware
für den export gefertigt wird
verarbeiten die betriebe im rotterdamer
hafen vor allem ankommende rohstoffe
der wichtigste industriezweig sind dabei
raffinerien und chemiewerke allein mehr
als 100 millionen tonnen rohöl kommen
jedes jahr in rotterdam an damit gehört
der hafen zu den größten erdöl
verarbeitungs zentren der welt
das öl kommt von bohrinseln in der
nordsee aus dem nahen osten und aus
russland riesige tankschiffe bringen es
in den hafen
alle großen mineralölkonzerne haben in
rotterdam affinerie
während eine hälfte des rohöls über
pipelines direkt weiter durch europa
fließt landet die andere hälfte in den
raffinerien und chemiefabriken des
hafens und wird dort zu kraftstoff und
chemischen produkten verarbeitet doch
nicht nur erdöl fließt durch rotterdam
hat
ein großteil der in europa verkauften
orangensaft es wird hier abgefüllt
25 prozent der weltweiten orangen ernte
kommen aus brasilien
dort werden die früchte geerntet
gewaschen und zu saft gepresst
anschließend entzieht man dem saft
wasser und es entsteht ein bis zu sieben
faches konzentrat das spart platz beim
transport tiefgekühlt kommt dieses
konzentrat dann in tankschiffen nach
europa im hafen von rotterdam wird aus
dem konzentrat wieder saft der direkt
abgefüllt wird die verarbeitung vor ort
egal ob öl oder orangensaft spart lager
und transportkosten für die firmen geht
es um milliarden
das fazit in sachen industriestandort
während der antike hafen von alexandria
mit handwerksbetrieben punktet sind es
bei seinem modernen gegenstück in
rotterdam vor allem die chemie und
erdölkonzerne die für den umsatz sorgen
dritter punkt in der kategorie features
wie sicher ist der hafen bei einem sturm
stürme gehören zu den größten gefahren
in der seefahrt das wissen auch die
alten ägypter und setzen alles daran den
hafen von alexandria und die schiffe zu
schützen
eine große rolle dabei spielt die
struktur des doppel hafens mit dem
hektar stadion
die durch die vorgelagerte insel und
dass raptor stadion war vor allem der
portos magnus gut vom meer abgeschirmt
der offene angelegte portus ist nicht
ganz so gut geschützt droht ein sturm
schleppt man die schiffe aus diesem
hafen teil durch die kanäle im hektar
stadion in den portos magnus und bringt
sie so aus der gefahrenzone
für zusätzlichen schutz bauen die
alexandrina außerdem vor den
hafeneinfahrten sogenannte wellenbrecher
dazu versenken arbeite riesige
steinblöcke im meer und türmen sie zu
einer art wall auf der bis knapp über
die wasseroberfläche reicht trifft eine
welle auf diese mauer bricht die welle
dadurch verliert sie einen teil ihrer
energie und ist nicht mehr so gefährlich
selbst bei starken winterstürmen waren
der hafen und die stoffe dadurch gut
geschützt im jahr 365 allerdings führt
ein starkes erdbeben vor der küste
griechenlands zu einem tsunami eine
gigantische welle rast über das
mittelmeer auf die ägyptische küste zu
die tsunami welle war eine der größten
der menschheitsgeschichte
der römische historiker am janus mattsee
- schrieb von schiffen die zwei meilen
weit ins land gespült wurden oder auf
hausdächern lagen
der tsunami zerstört einen großen teil
alexandrias und ihres legendären hafens
es dauert viele jahre alles wieder
aufzubauen einen perfekten schutz vor
den naturgewalten gibt es allerdings bis
heute nicht
rotterdam und sein hafen werden rund
1600 jahre später von einer gewaltigen
sturmflut überrollt
es war die grösste 90 sturmflut des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts niemand dachte
dass es so schlimm werden würde
in der nacht auf den ersten februar 1953
sterben fast 1900 menschen allein in den
niederlanden
danach startet die regierung ein
gigantisches hochwasserschutzprogramm
[Musik]
neben fast 100 kilometer neuer dämme
errichten sie ein sperrwerk an der
mündung des neue weiter weg den mess
land caring er soll den hafen und die
innenstadt bei einer erneuten sturmflut
schützen
[Musik]
die herausforderung war eine
konstruktion zu bauen die im notfall den
hasen schützt aber im alltag den
schiffsverkehr nicht behindert
das sperrwerk besteht aus zwei
bogenförmigen toren sie sind 22 meter
hoch und jeweils 210 meter lang die
gesamte konstruktion besteht aus drei
mal so viel stahl wie der eiffelturm in
paris
normalerweise sind die tore in
trockendocks am ufer geparkt die schiffe
können ungehindert passieren
bei einer drohenden sturmflut schließt
ein computer die tore automatisch dazu
werden die dogs geflutet die tore
schwimmen auf und werden über die neue
wasserweg geschwenkt
das kann eine welle von bis zu fünf
metern abhalten
bei einer sturmflut ist der hafen so gut
geschützt ob das sperrwerk auch schutz
vor einem tsunami bietet ist allerdings
nicht sicher gegen die naturgewalten ist
der moderne hafen von rotterdam dank
neuester technik deutlich besser
gerüstet als sein gegenstück im alten
ägypten
das fazit in der kategorie features bei
innovation und industrie kann der antike
hafen locker mit seiner modernen
gegenstück mithalten in sachen sturm
sicherheit ist rotterdam allerdings
überlegen
mehr als 2000 jahre liegen zwischen der
erbauung des antiken hafen von
alexandria
und seine modernen konterpart dem hafen
von rotterdam
beide können die größten schiffe ihrer
zeit aufnehmen und sind in sachen
warenumschlag und innovationen anderen
häfen weit überlegen
noch heute ist der hafen von alexandria
für seinen gigantischen leuchtturm
bekannt
[Musik]
und der hafen von rotterdam gilt auf der
ganzen welt als hafen der zukunft
[Applaus]